fun isn't something one considers from
balancing the universe
[Applause]
[Music]
hey everybody big surprise we got a
whole bunch of new infinity war to break
down and Avengers for it looks like we
have some confirmation about what's
going on with visions infinity stone so
everybody's seen the trailer but the
actor Paul Bettany posted pictures of
himself in full makeup finishing on
Avengers 4 along with Scarlet Witch so
she just finished her filming on
Avengers 4-2
[Music]
so if you weren't aware they were
filming Avengers infinity war and
Avengers for back to back because it's
really two different parts of the Thanos
infinity saga even though they're saying
that Avengers 4 is gonna be very
different from infinity war largely it's
still a Thanos versus The Avengers movie
with the Infinity Gauntlet is the big
MacGuffin like oh my god he's gonna wipe
out all of reality and Pokemon style
he's gonna have to collect all the
infinity gems it's just that all the
collecting happens largely during
infinity war and then a little bit
during Avengers 4 because everybody saw
the trailer and even though they cut
trailers to be very misleading looking
over at thor ragnarok where we have this
picture of Thanos with just a couple of
the gems in the gauntlet definitely
without the mind gem but maybe you know
status pending about the time gem
because it's on the thumb the thumb has
bent backwards so they're just leaving
you to wonder whether or not they knows
has already taken it from Doctor Strange
when he's punching Iron Man here but
based on the images that they posted we
have a better picture for how that's
going to play out
so if you are finding me for the first
time be sure to subscribe to get
everything there's gonna be so much
infinity war in black panther stuff
dropping in the next couple of weeks but
also Deadpool 2 which is kind of a
separate thing but not separate because
of the x-men Disney deal that's going on
right now the reality of this situation
is that he's fighting Proxima midnight
in Corvus glaive it looks like Scarlet
Witch at least is there to help them and
it comes after whatever sexytime moment
they're happening in this hotel because
remember this is a really big movie with
a lot of characters so even though
they're teasing this special vacation
that they're on we're probably only
gonna get a few scenes with them doing
that stuff with him going full Pinocchio
making himself look like a real boy
before we get our big attack scene and
it looks like it's happening
simultaneously all over the earth so
spider-man here in Queens on his way to
school seized the ship materialized in
the skies over New York well at the same
time Proxima midnight and Corvus glaive
are going after the mine stone and as
for who is in this ship here this is at
least
evany mob because we know from the
trailer as well as the comics that he's
the person that goes after dr. strange
because the only way to take the time
stone from Doctor Strange is to be able
to pierce his mind with your magic in
the various specific powers of each of
the black order members is just tailored
to the
Avengers that they're going after but
the whole point here is this is meant to
be their first big fight where they get
their asses handed to them barely crawl
away then they rally and have these
other two big bites on what looks like
the ruins of the Nova Corps along with
Wakanda so even though these movies are
ginormous a lot of what you're seeing is
all happening at the same time so the
amount of time that passes between the
beginning of the first infinity war
movie in Avengers 4 isn't that great
even though within the movies they jump
around in time a lot like literally with
the time gem along with flash bags we've
seen those scenes of them behind the
scenes wearing their outfits from the
first Avengers film so the actual
sequence of events in the timeline of
the movie is very misleading but when
they showed up to work on Avengers 4
Paul Bettany was wearing his full
practical vision makeup he had the mind
stone still stuck in his forehead so
people are like wait a minute
what does this mean 1 it means he
survives Avengers infinity war whatever
happens with the mine stone but it also
Loki confirms what happens during this
Proxima midnight Corvus glaive bite
because I think you have Scarlet Witch
there and I think she's really the
deciding factor she's one of the other
most powerful Avengers so even though
Falcon here is a total badass love
Anthony Mackie to death him trying to
kick one of the Black Order and take
them down is hilarious
you really need someone as powerful as
vision or Scarlet Witch to fight them
off which you have both of so it looks
like this scene here with him just
breathing deeply like they just barely
fought them off and they're barely alive
is him with the mind gem still in his
forehead but they cut it in a misleading
way so there would still be a little bit
of mystery but then you see pictures
like this of him wrapping all of his
scenes during Avengers 4 and you're like
oh it's still in his forehead during
Avengers 4 so that confirms a couple big
plot points but remember like I said the
timeline of the movie is very misleading
so just because he ends the movie with
the mind gem in his forehead doesn't
mean that it's always going to be in his
forehead because Thanos needs to form
the Infinity Gauntlet he needs all six
gems to do that it sounds like he'll get
the mind gem at some point during
Avengers 4 and then there's some rumors
from behind the scenes about description
of playsets that
involve the removal of visions mind gem
using some special Wakanda and
technology but a lot of that's
conjecture a lot of times the toys from
the movies don't really tell you what's
actually happening during the movie
Star Wars is the best example of that
they will sell a toy for every single
creature in the movie regardless of how
much that creature appears in the movie
like they hyped porgies up so much but
there's actually not that much porks in
the last Jedi so when your theory
crafting using some of this
behind-the-scenes stuff just be careful
how deep you go into toy sets
speculation because it can all turn out
to be nothing and remember that they're
shooting so much footage for all these
that will hit the cutting room floor
because even though we're all expecting
infinity war and Avengers 4 to be really
long in duration Marvel movies just
because they're so big I actually don't
think they're gonna be that much longer
than movies like Captain America Civil
War which are still well over 2 hours
long but I don't think it's gonna be
longer than 2 and a half hours people
flipped a little bit when they found out
Star Wars the last Jedi was going to be
the longest Star Wars movie of all time
and it wound up being two and a half
hours and people felt like there was a
lot that could come out of that I'm
expecting the same treatment with
infinity war like people want a really
long movie but it'll probably wind up
being closer to 2 hours and 20 minutes
we'll see about Avengers 4 we'll just
have to tailor our expectations based on
the future trailers that we get for
infinity war they'll start dropping in
the next month or so
but let me know what do you think about
the idea of vision just getting pounded
during infinity war in Avengers 4 and
then him just repairing himself because
he's one of the few characters that you
can actually do that to he can upload
himself to other things you can rip his
body apart the way you could not do with
a human and then put him back together
so it sounds like they're gonna have
some fun with that during infinity war
in Avengers 4 so he makes out of this
alive because Paul Bettany is going to
resize whatever contract Marvel puts in
front of him he makes way too much money
for him to walk away from the Marvel
Universe so almost confirmed biggest
theory here vision walks into Marvel
phase 4 doing just fine regardless of
which movies they decide to put him in
because there is a real question about
where you put a character like vision if
you're not gonna have an Avengers movie
within two years of Avengers 4 it would
be way below his pay grade as Tony Stark
says
would be hilarious to see visions show
up as a teacher at Peter's school Bruce
Banner - I actually really want to see
Bruce Banner show off so that they can
do some funny Hulk stuff during the next
spider-man homecoming movie but there's
a new round of that ticket giveaway all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber leave a comment on the video
congratulations to the winner from my
last video Arthur Rosa please private
message me so I can get your contact
details there'll be a new round when I
post new marble later this week just
leave all your bonus video requests
everybody still has a billion Fox Marvel
questions but there will be some new
Deadpool really soon - click here for
more of that and click here to re-watch
that Deadpool trailer thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight
[Music]